hello and uh good morning good afternoon
wherever you are i'm raghav indran and
i'm a research consultant and mentor
with amid storage i'm trained in
bioinformatics and i hold up heard a phd
in computational biology from max bank
institute of germany my research
interests are mainly uh on data science
techniques such as machine learning and
deep learning methods applied to
integration of transcript transcriptomic
data with the other multi-omics profiles
such as somatic mutation copy number
variation and others etc
to understand cancer genomics and in the
field of neurological disorders and also
to study plant bioinformatics please let
me talk about one such example where i
develop machine learning models to
predict tumor responses to a variety of
treatment options primarily using
transcriptomic data and also when
transcriptomic gene expression data was
supplemented with mutation data and copy
number variation data so to go into that
we have to
get some background so we know that
cancer is the leading cause of disease
deaths worldwide so for such a dreadful
disease systematic cancer treatments uh
have relied on chemotherapeutic
chemotherapeutic drugs that are
marginally toxic to cancer cells
thermometers this is a huge problem
because on an average only 25 percentage
of the cancer patients respond to such
cancer drugs and such cancer treatments
so in comparison about 80 percentage of
the patients respond
positively to popular painkillers that
are available in the market so one
prominent solution to this problem
is precision oncological therapy where
the treatment strategy is designed by
targeting the molecular characteristics
of patients tumor hence the treatment is
personalized to patients who are likely
to respond to specific cancer therapies
but there is not sufficiently enough
data from cancer patients to molecularly
characterize tumor under multitude of
different treatment options so we have
to rely on suitable model system
you might have had a very good
introduction to patient-derived
xenograph model system from eliabroski's
talk but let me cover it little briefly
here so we have covered why we have to
do such a study and
how how is it done the tumor cells from
the cancer patients are subjected to
next-gen sequencing methods and
techniques and the information about
gene expression data and gene mutation
data and epigenetic variation data and
copy number variation data are all
extracted
these data molecularly characterize the
tumors and these tumors samples are then
grafted into immunosuppressed mouse and
administered several cancer drugs these
mouse or mice models are called as
patient-derived xenograft models and
then when these tumor
when these mouse or mice models are
are given different treatment profiles
their tumor response to the respective
drugs are documented and this data
records a tumor's reaction to different
treatments so both the molecular
characterization data and the treatment
response data are available with the uh
with the
with the publication published by
novartis so
such a lot of data such as wealth of
data generates a lot of research
questions and my interest was
specifically to use this data to design
and implement machine learning models to
predict tumors response to different
treatments so what did we find so first
we find that the traditional use of
using a single gene biomarker to predict
tumors response to any given treatment
was not accurate enough at all that you
can see from the from this part of the
graph where the accuracy of the model
increases as it approaches one and
decreases
when it approaches minus one so
traditional model of single gene uh
markers did not accurately predict the
treatment responses of breast cancer to
these multitude of different treatments
but when such a traditional model was uh
sorry when when i used uh instead of one
gene model okay
when i use instead of a single gene
model
but
a multitude of gene models and
supplement it with the transcriptomic
profile data and copy number variation
data and gene mutation data so what i
observe is most of the
what i observe is most of the prediction
accuracies lie on the north side of the
0.5 which is regarded as a very good
accuracy for such a
limited data set so that is also seen in
the distribution of the accuracy across
the treatments which is so scattered
when i use single gene uh mutation data
which is traditionally used to
multi-omics integration data which are
uh for which the machine learning model
was developed so
what more can be done with such a such a
question and such a data so a gene
certain gene set enrichment analysis can
be performed on the most informative
genes that are identified from machine
learning analysis and then this can be
extrapolated to study and identify
specific biomarkers that can predict and
help us understand tumors response to
different treatments and one can also
extend such an analysis to include
patients data from tcga repository and
that would reveal us interesting
insights into performance of the machine
learning models that are trained on
pre-clinical data but tested on
real-world patient data and
hope this example was very informative
and inspiring for you all to generate
interesting research questions to
perform such an analysis coding was an
interesting i mean was an integral part
for me but if one latch or one is
restricted in encoding experience that
should not deter them from asking such
interesting questions and this is where
i think omixlogic platform bridges that
gap by providing the necessary trading
modules and also necessary platform
required to perform such impactful
research and i thank you for thank you
all